TONIGHT.HROUGH THE
LEAFS "D" AND MAKES IT A
1-NOTHING LEAD FOR WINNIPEG..
NOW GIORDANO HAS NO PUSH INTO
THE MIDDLE AND WHEE
NIKOLAJ EHLERS WORKS IN, DROPS
IT BACK AND A QUICK SHOT BY
AST
FOR STASTNY, GOAL YS.
THEY'VE HAD HHE LEAFS
ARE BACK ON T.
DROPS IT BACK.FT WITH GIORDANO
STAY MENTIONED THE FOURTH
FORMER NORRIS TROPHY WINNER TO
PLAY FOR
PERIOD, DUBOIS WITHMATTHEWS BAC
RIELWS IN THE
SHOOTING SPOT FROM PLAYS IT BAC.
KALLGREN LOST HIS GOAL STICK, A
WORKED AROUND, HE'S GOING TO, AE
MARNER LOOKS BACK TORDED FOR
IT.
WHILE MORRISSEY GETORRISSEY POK
EHLERS.
HE DOESN'T HAVED UP IN THE
NET.
>> Gord:d:BOUND.
BROUGHT B TO
NYLANDER, SHOOTS AND COMLETON A
TIMES IN THE EARLY 80s, GARY
AND SAID, NO, THAT'S ENOUGH OF
THAT.
SO THE L LILJEGREN IS ACTUALLY N
THE ICE WITH GIORDANO AND H